all right here's the first story from
the hill second batch of classified
Biden documents found at new location a
second batch of classified documents
belonging to President Biden was
reportedly discovered by White House
aides days after discovery of public
documents from a former private office
the new batch was found in a separate
location from the first
okay I just you know part of me was like
why even bother reporting this at this
point we get it the Democrats do these
things over and over again Joe Biden as
vice president had no powers to
declassify anything nor did Hillary
Clinton as Secretary of State but Donald
Trump should either go to jail or be
ineligible for public office because
they found classified documents at his
house but when it comes to Joe Biden
it's uh it's no big deal he's
cooperating it's whatever why why would
they report why would the White House
report this about Biden are they trying
to get out ahead on something or create
like a thing that oh it turned out it
wasn't that bad now everything can be
put to rest or Biden came to him it's
like you know we can't really ban gas
stoves and then the real powers that be
yes we can we're gonna get you in
trouble look at all the documents you
left document the the poor the poor guy
is forgetful so I don't think he even
knows what's going on here but he was
confused even a few days ago mixing up a
uniformed Salvation Army member for a
secret service agent specifically
talking about all the great things and
all the great times he had with the
Secret Service so I mean the guy's not
there he's not really up there now the
documents that were found originally
were related to Intel related to of
course Ukraine Iran the United Kingdom
he of course was a vice president this
this is all happening a few years ago
this this release actually was caught
the day before the mid to term elections
that of course this is the second
release I don't know I'm talking about
the first release that's happening right
now
um and the the office that it was found
was related to a think tank that was
also allegedly connected to a lot of
money coming in from China so a lot of
questions surrounding uh those first
documents that were you know classified
that were found in that private office
what are these documents related to we
don't know yet uh I think we're only
going to find out a few days from now
but again they are classified so I
wonder if what I wonder if what we're
actually going to be finding out is
going going to be relevant to anyone so
impeached Joe Biden yeah impeach
everybody you know have an impeachment
party Biden says he was unaware of uh
Which documents were found which ones
were found yeah I know I don't even know
what I was taking illegally okay that's
the defense that's the thing though
about a president leaves office they've
got all these AIDS moving boxes of
paperwork this and that if like six
papers with like confidential things
that are like don't tell the guy's last
name in The foodie ate like ah who cares
so what if it was like State secrets and
it's like blatantly destroying our
national security for some reason now I
understand but like dude just you can
classify almost anything as the
president so like but he was the vice
president when yeah he's not allowed to
do that yeah he's not allowed to
declassify documents as the vice
president I'm curious James your
thoughts I know like your organization
is is very very focused on one issue
right but you but you aren't just like
you're you're conservative I am a
conservative I'm I'm right-wing yes so I
mean I mean I I I can no
yeah oh my God no I'm incredibly
offended that that could even possibly
be up for question now I'm basically
with Luke here where the guy has no idea
like what he's doing
um I mean I don't know how long he's
been suffering from such severe dementia
but uh I think it's been a while I don't
think back then he was though but um you
know we don't know what the documents
are exactly but I think that you know
it's telling that the left seems to not
give a single crap about the issue you
know they're running cover for him when
you know they were trying to prosecute
Trump for the same thing he made a good
point you said that you you didn't think
his brain like how do you say that back
then his brain wasn't as broken not as
broken I feel like it was pretty broken
no but hold on but hold on in terms of
like dementia you know yeah and Ian just
said that Biden didn't know he knew back
then yeah I understand him not knowing
now yeah now he doesn't know I mean he
doesn't know where he is he walked up to
a Salvation Army guy and was like I
spent a lot of time with a secret
service and the Salvation Army guys
wearing it says Salvation Army on his
chest and he's just like what's
happening honestly I live for these
moments with Joe Biden like they give me
so much entertainment and and honestly
it's just you know you have to laugh at
the state of things otherwise you're
going to be very very depressed every
single day so yeah humor and human you
know it's a basic part of what we use as
human can we even be human without humor
but that you know laughing at this
sometimes it feels like riding the the
nuclear bomb down you know doing the
Yeehaw thing like like was that Dr
strangelover yeah yeah at the end of
strange love but this leaves me with the
question is he just an old man with
dementia is he a puppet or is he a
criminal mastermind selling secrets to
China so they give him lucrative
contracts to his son what's going on
here what do you think is going on here
what's your take on what if what if
Hunter is weakened at Bernie Zing his
dad I mean I think I think he initially
started as you know he he was not always
a very um mentally incapacitated man
um I think he has had deals with China
going on for a long time
um I think now he doesn't know what deal
is what or what exists and what doesn't
um maybe a little I don't know I think
they pump him full of a lot of meds that
that give him a little bit of um Clarity
for moments in time
um but I think he definitely knew what
was going on when these deals were
originally created
um and I'm sure he knows about them now
but you know doesn't really doesn't
really focus on it too much to
to know much about it anymore what are
you think Ian um puppet Mastermind it's
certainly a puppet of a greater scheme I
was thinking last night about the world
in general and like most of the world is
sex trafficking murder bribery
destruction uh prostitution slavery kind
of thing like that's most of the world
we happen to be in this like Ivory Tower
of the United States where we have kind
of LED ourselves to believe that's not
the way things are and that when it
comes up and when we see it it's like an
aberration of the reality but the
reality is like kids are being
trafficked it's the largest business on
Earth it's human trafficking I'm pretty
sure
um and so that that government I was
like picturing talking to Obama about
he's like yo I have no I mean there's
people I don't know who's running the
show I don't know
I think he would be straight up I think
a lot of past presidents if you get them
to be straight up will be like dude we
are such a small part of what's going on
in the world even though we think we
have the best military
um so I think Biden's a puppet long
story short I think they're being
controlled by Big Money the liberal
economic order the bank for
international settlements deciding where
the money goes that the Federal Reserve
is even going to give the US government
money and so we're kind of beholding to
the stakeholders in that sense uh or at
least we think we are stakeholders I
wouldn't even say he's a puppet at this
point I think he's just like a a little
figurehead just just you know that sits
there in the chair in the Oval Office
and and goes to these things but you
know everything he says is completely
you know in his ear at all times he
doesn't know what he's doing
um but he just I think is just kind of
put there for show but yeah all
presidents really uh you know they
always have people behind the the scenes
it feels like aliens took the country
over and then just like placed Biden
there yeah because Bernie Sanders was
going to win in 2020. he was dominating
that I don't know that has to do with
aliens Ian well all of a sudden like
seven eight weeks after the Bernie had
been running or four weeks or something
all of a sudden Biden is running now he
didn't even mention running for
president president for four years
before that someone picked him and put
him there I mean that's mine it's
surprising to me that that's you know
out of all the people that they could
have picked the Democrats could have
picked like they went with this senile
old man but it's because he's the
sacrificial lamb right their attitude is
whoever we put in place for this this
next term is going to be hated by
everybody because there's so much bad
stuff going on yeah they know he's not
going to sell him out either why waste a
Buddha judge you know Buddha judge has
got his whole life out of him it's like
Joe Biden's on his way out so they're
like hey it's you know you know it's
like you know when you go to a grocery
store and you're looking at the milk the
milk right up front by the glass expires
in like three days but if you go in the
back it like it'll last another decision
which one do you take well you take the
one in the back now I'm not buying the
milk it's gonna expire in three days
that's like buying that's like voting
for Joe Biden and going in the back is
that is the santis and and going to your
local farm and getting raw milk is a
form of Anarchy which I think more
people should do more than ever no but
even Biden himself would say that he's
like a bridge he's like a bridge
president to go from like this one air
to another and so he even knows his
place like in this you know and I don't
know if he's going to run again he's
already campaigning I guess but it's
like do does his own party even want him
to run again Joe Biden will never run
again he's too old I made that joke
twice I think he's going to try it maybe
he'll run I hope he's got physical
health
that's what I'm saying I think they
inject him with stuff right before he's
going to be honestly his IV oh yeah he
held up his hands and you could track
mark track marks yeah no they they pump
that man full of uh plenty of goofballs
yeah
they put him in as a placeholder knowing
he won't Squawk on the liberal economic
order because his son is so deeply
involved with barisman with China and he
himself has been so involved with it
dude he was stealing is this considered
stealing classified documents if you
walk out of there as the vice president
and take them well the the reason why
you know Biden is a perfect puppet is
because there's so much dirt on him he's
known as being one of the sleaziest
politicians in Washington DC he's been
in there for decades and he's known as
the the the politician for the lobbyist
even Barack Obama warned specifically
hey if if Biden ever becomes in power
the lobbyist will have a lot of control
over Washington DC now I'm paraphrasing
here I don't remember the exact words
but I remember talking about this a few
years ago where even Barack Obama was
worried about the special interests that
were involved with Biden and when you're
in DC for so long when you're in that
private club when you go to a lot of
these private meetings and get-ups and
islands and whatever it may be there is
so much dirt on you there is so much bad
things that you have done there's so
much room ample opportunities for
corrupted deals to go through and it's
pretty clear whether it's China whether
it's Ukraine whether it's even Russia a
lot of money exchanged hands especially
with his family so to think that he uh
is is is you know doing you know
something that's great I I think his
Dimension I think his his cognitive
abilities are used as a distraction for
who he really is the larger swap monster
that isn't really in charge but is a
conduit for the real people who are in
charge yeah his I mean if you want to go
personal on the guy you got to look at
Tara Reid because her allegations
against him and what he did to her in I
don't know if it was the Capitol
Building or one of those buildings there
uh was is pretty grotesque I mean she
says that he's sexually assaulted her
and she's very graphic about what he did
to her up against the wall and then
sounds like what he does and before he
walked away says you're she she rebuffed
him and he was like you're dead to me or
you're nothing you're nothing I think
this is a guy who's on camera sniffing
little girls and pinching and groping
them so it's like when you hear an
allegation it's kind of like oh you know
whose own daughter in her own diary
Ashley right wrote specifically how she
didn't she had to take showers at night
because she was afraid that he would
come in there freaking horrific
anecdotal horrific remember when he
broke his leg and he said the dog did it
yeah maybe he was trying to sneak in the
shower on like his granddaughter and
they decided to fight back
with the way things go down right that's
plausible you know again we don't have
any direct evidence of this we're kind
of speculating here but I think if you
look how Sinister and evil a lot of
these people are I I could see the
granddaughter just saying I I need to
practice martial law putting him in like
a martial law I'm sorry
uh what's the correct answer
practicing martial arts and then
snapping the leg of the person when you
when you imagine this you need to
imagine that it's it's very dark there's
a thunderstorm Biden's got a gigantic
grin as usual
all that facial work stay away I think
you're right Luke to not make the the
dementia like that it's the dimension is
a smoke screen for his behavior um like
Ronald Reagan I remember near the end of
his second term got them like
Alzheimer's I think they were saying
he's coming out with Alzheimer's but he
was also under investigation like
the concern that he had done some
illegal things I don't know the whole
story maybe you guys know more about it
didn't he think that Matthew Broderick
movie was real
that was a thing war games yeah yeah he
thought that was real he started
claiming that he didn't remember a lot
of stuff from his terms that's the thing
like Biden had you know when he
committed all these crimes and did all
this Shady stuff
um he didn't have dementia then I don't
think I mean you know now he does which
everybody can clearly see but there is a
this is a different Joe Biden in this
era that we're dealing with than like
who he used to be
um and he's been in politics for what
like 40 years he's been something like
that 50. has it really pretty sure it's
50 years yeah absolutely he's been in
there for for such a long time and he
looks uh pretty different especially
from the last few years there's a lot of
different photos the earlobes you can
tell I mean I think he's he's gotten a
lot of plastic surgery too but also a
lot of the things just look totally
different on him than they ever did
before but I I'm calling it here I think
he's going to run he's going to win the
the next upcoming election and then the
third one and then the fourth one just
like FDR who was partly paralyzed and
still was able to of course successfully
be president of the United States for a
very long that was before the amendment
of course now it's term limits like hey
that could be overturned during uh do
you vote for Hunter Biden
might as well right now Biden fetterman
I'm calling it's going to happen Hunter
Hunter Biden is kind of like the Anarchy
vote in my opinion because it's just
like it all comes crashing down if you
vote for someone like Hunter button I'd
rather vote for Kanye West than anybody
else sorry I love your name though we
talked about it before but I'd love to
watch a hunter Biden YouTube channel
yeah it would just be like like a live
stream just a 24-hour live stream I
don't know but not like a vlog him just
being like yo what up everybody Hunter
mind here just scored some crack
kids and grandkids of the Rockefeller
like the young Rockefellers young
Rothschilds young bidens to come out and
tell the world what really has been
happening I would love to see wouldn't
that be amazing if they did one day they
just like fig you know they just decided
like they're done with being these evil
people and they want to expose it all
same with the royal family the young
like Harry I got so much faith that he
and nobody thinks they're evil though
the Rothschilds and stuff like like pop
like no person like there are some
people like like I can't remember which
serial killer but there's like a serial
killer who was like yup I know what I'm
doing is it might have been Dahmer yeah
and he's like what I'm doing is wrong
and I know it and I should be locked up
but I can't stop but right but but when
you're taking you know human excrement
and blood and writing messages on the
wall trying to summon in demons I I
think that that crosses a different
level here of of what people actually
see and understand people doing it don't
think that they are evil I think they're
Heroes but or they're entitled or
something so you were you were questions
like other people how other people see
the roster trials and stuff like I and I
feel like you know maybe the kids of
these families like they're not kids
anymore now but like I don't know or
their kids you know the younger people
in the families that maybe don't feel
the same don't want to be part of the
same cabal like can see through it yeah
I mean a lot of them I don't know maybe
one day they'll decide to tell all a lot
of them are sociopaths so I I don't know
if sociopaths recognize that they are
evil
um we would have to get someone who's
you know studied this topic to talk
about this specifically but when we look
at Washington DC it has the highest per
capital sociopaths than almost anywhere
else in the United States and there also
is a theory that what Hunter Biden is
doing is trying to get some sort of
redemption against the father who wasn't
there for him or might have potentially
hurt him before and this is Hunter Biden
kind of releasing a lot of this
information getting it out there to the
general public on purpose that's one of
the theories out there in order to hurt
his father and and get some kind of
Justice thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time